the Joe Rogan experience how did you
respond when you saw yourself get
stabbed I was a little I was a little
confused and then I was like I was very
aggressive I didn't understand the
carrot either what was up with the
carrot
it's from Stephen Segal that's who I was
dressed I know that the president of
Belarus gave him a Care is like the
Conor thing the president of Belarus
gave him a carrot one time and then
Seagal just ate it it's just weird
so is the [ __ ] jet-black hair her
hair is so ridiculous like sixty two we
were in the whoops and then we said one
day Tom your numbers were through the
roof news like yeah I got lost in the
canyons and you were filming he was
filming and he was dancing okay it was
my uh my what's it called um whoop if
you exert the activity level right 19.8
that day yeah you know like it was fifty
eight hundred calories burned it was
[ __ ] it was killer weed remember that
one day where I burned six thousand
calories you know like what the [ __ ]
hunting oh yeah go up the mountains it's
just Halim out here and ten hours a day
that's how you guys gonna strap the year
before yeah all day long Wow I got you
because I'm a psycho yeah really I was
gonna get you no matter what oh yeah I
told you guys you gotta be ready to die
but that's why we wanted you in the
dance video we want to see what you
would do that's no joke no time right
now I know you will you will break the
two of us in half crying laughing if
just one day on your own you film some
dance video that's better than ours you
realize that oh that's good keep going
like that and this surprises surprise
hi laughs sorry I actually talked about
our II had a great idea about doing one
yeah Ari had a great idea of us
recreating the scene from dirty dancing
I am beeper beep that's it that's
exactly what we're talking about yeah
just guys just take a weekend it all
takes a weekend well I would have to
catch him
he's not gonna catch me
we like a buck 70 at least right
yeah wrong with 75 so a box 70 like that
that's a lot of weight man you got to be
prepared I would have to train for that
you have to train for it I'd have to do
a lot of heavy kettlebells you know cuz
that's dead weight here it is just what
is all seen you know sorry and sent okay
this is awkward yeah this is gonna be a
problem no matter what because you've
gotta wear that dress you've got to wear
that dress obvious I already have the
dress in the nose he kissed me though
the problem is we got that close our
would sneak in a kiss you definitely
would you guys got to do nope not doing
it
dude I learned how to dance for that
[ __ ] zookeeper movie it was a long
two weeks of learning and I got to dance
with Leslie Bibb who's hot and cool I'm
hot I'm cool you're cool all right
please give it cool
[Applause]